hi how can we help you laughs yes how
can we help you oh yes my mom is 78
years old and she has been on statin
drugs for several years and she's
showing signs of dementia okay what is
she way she weighs a hundred and eight
pounds mono hates small lady okay
and does she have any other issues how
would pressure diabetes arthritis yeah
high blood pressure that's why they had
her on the statin drugs which don't care
in the past she had cataracts and kidney
stones and she does have hay fever
allergies
okay kidney stones allergies does she
have any skin problems or anything like
that
no her skin looks great actually okay
what about her bowels any constipation
diarrhea belly pain that kind of stuff
Crohn's disease everyone I know every
once in a while she had mentioned she
has diarrhea but not very often
okay well it's kinda like being pregnant
okay either he's Irene right okay
Charmaine this gal is about your size
her mother mom is 108 pounds about your
size and so what diet would you put her
on to begin with - of course you want
her to stay on the stands or get off oh
no we took her off of them oh you did
already okay so what would you what kind
of dad would you put her on to support
healthy memory well she needs to be on
the high good fat diet like eggs and
butter mm-hmm and so she could listen to
the end and Patricia you need to listen
to that CD a stick of butter day keeps a
doctor way that's and doing all the
issue and at 108 pounds I never take
three eggs twice a day they can be
poached soft yolks soft ball soft sauce
scramblin butter no oil is no margin no
overeasy no fried eggs okay and then
what supplement program would you give
her Charmaine well for issues I think I
would get her on a healthy brain and
heart back and then I would add the
ultimate daily classic and she
should be good to go and maybe some
vitamin d3 okay I heard her age vitamin
d3 and some what else would you throw in
first well she probably has kidney
stones which means she has osteoporosis
yes well the healthy brain and heart
Peck has stuff in there but she could
take some extra give us an image him
remember some yeah and Google job for
that matter too and Luca jelly yep
and so it her body weight how many how
many gluco gel do you take you away 110
pounds well per I try to take 12 a day
okay so 12 a days of the gluco gel
capsules and you take six and six I know
you take it twice a day
yep and then what about the MSM the MSM
I just take two twice a day so I take
four day of those okay so she could take
two or three twice a day because she has
kidney stones and so and and see here
[Music]
okay so what would you do in addition to
the eggs would you do what would you
throw in for that to support really
better memory and brain function in
addition to you would suggest she takes
a nap those synaptic very good synaptic
as yn okay apt IV kinda like synapses
it's the raw materials for the brain to
make neurotransmitters so the brain
cells can talk to each other but people
recover very quickly and get their
memory back and so forth taking away the
bad stuff okay which is the statin drugs
because cholesterol is your best friend
remember your brain is 75% white matter
and that white matter of your brain is
almost 100 percent cholesterol as it
goes away remember we talked earlier in
the show as you're to all tissues all
tissues as it goes away if you're not
replacing it
you get diseases and so you must replace
that cholesterol that you're losing
every day from you're a mile in the
white white matter in the brain and
other tissues in the body hormones and
no thing and related being ovaries
that'll be testicles and so on and so
it's imperative to replace everything
you're losing and that way your body can
maintain itself it requires raw material
to do that stuff so call us if you would
every couple of weeks of Patricia it'll
take about two to three days to get the
products into Arizona but you can start
your mom's diet adjustments today and
then call us every two weeks and we'll
walk you through this